what is the minimum level of CO2
necessary in the atmosphere currently we
are concerned with limiting the Increase
of CO2 we'd really like to keep CO2
levels below about 500 parts per million
or PPM in the atmosphere in order to
limit climate change and to be super
clear the problem isn't actually that
number it's how quickly that number is
changing far faster than what we've seen
in the past anyway as we know too much
CO2 and we boil but too little and we
freeze and plants don't have anything to
eat so how low can this number go and
life still survives well on geological
scales we're near historic lows for CO2
rarely in the past half billion years
have CO2 levels dipped as low as they
were just before the start of the
Industrial Revolution about 2 180 parts
per million a study in 1995 looked at
how plants grew in different levels of
CO2 and found that most plants on Earth
need about 150 parts per million a
absolute minimum in order to survive and
at that CO2 concentration the planet
would be livable from a temperature
perspective just uh the biosphere would
kind of collapse and no it's not worth
increasing the level of CO2 just for
plants I've made a whole video about
this